historically the fact that this property
is called dot prototype has been very
confusing for people learning JavaScript
by using this word to describe the
methods container object that's
available on every function javascript
introduces an ambiguous second meaning
for the word prototype so if someone
says object one's prototype is object to
a reasonable interpretation would be to
think that failed lookups on this first
object should fall through to the second
one so you might say Ami's prototype is
car dot prototype but this is not the
relationship that car has with car dot
prototype in that case car is a function
object and failed lookups on it will
fall through to some function prototype
where all function objects delegate
their failed lookups the car functions
relationship with car dot prototype is
very different from the one that amy has
with car dot prototype this other
relationship reflects the second
interpretation of the statement object
one's prototype is object to the
relationship is that when a car function
runs it will create objects that
delegate their failed lookups to car dot
prototype so in this sense you might say
car's prototype is car dot prototype so
to review saying amy's prototype is car
dot prototype means something very
different from saying car's prototype is
car dot prototype even though those
sentences look so similar we can leave
this discussion behind but be aware that
it's extremely easy to conflate these
two uses of the word prototype and it's
well worth investing extra thought in
ironing out exactly what the difference
is between the two uses are